well I'm joined Now by Nick curios the
interview nobody on planet Earth thought
would ever happen is now about to happen
so Nick how are you good Piers how are
you how's everything going well I
thought it might be useful for viewers
who are not familiar with our beef I
believe is the vernacular term these
days to go over the beef over the last
few years and explain how we reached
this place um it goes back to 2016 you
played Andy Murray sounds good uh you
threw a legendary stro even by your
standards and I tweeted the following
never seen an Australian Suk like curios
normally ferocious proud competitors
embarrassing uh I then added you should
put your toys back in the pram to which
you responded E A now I didn't know what
EAD meant until one of my sons informed
me it meant eat a
dick so perhaps we could start with that
one nick uh um it was a very you know it
was a very to the point comment uh do
you have any regrets about your response
or did you think it was fair enough um
yeah I think it was I think it was
warranted definitely um I actually sent
that from a from a restaurant I had a
couple beers and I saw your comment on
Twitter and I was just like I'm in no
mood to deal with anything like this at
the moment and I just sent it so yeah I
mean look Andy Murray he's an absolute
legend of the sport and yeah I got I got
given a lesson that day and yeah it was
not a good show for me but I guess a
couple years later made the final of
wimon so you would have enjoyed seeing
that right well funny enough you weren't
the only person to to come back at me
with a comment like that on Twitter
around that period Rihanna uh I told her
to grow her hair after she revealed some
short bob when she appeared on stage in
London and she replied grow a dick so
there was a running theme to uh to
Global figures uh basically calling me a
dick in various ways I mean you can't
blame her for calling you one sometimes
you are a bit of a a bit of a dick I
guess well I got to say coming from you
pot
Kettle now look I've been called a lot
worse than
that well let's move to the second phase
of the of the beef uh in an interview
with the New York Times after this
exchange which got a bit of traction
online as we know uh you confessed you
confessed you never watched tennis y and
you responded no chance Jesus I'd rather
watch Piers
Morgan yeah I mean that's that's
actually a compliment you should take
that as a compliment because I'd
actually probably rather watch one of
your segments on TV than a tennis match
so that's actually I don't know why you
would take that as beef that's a
compliment like you're you're
entertaining so and we all know that
that's why people watch me from time to
time it's not also about the quality
it's just about you know how much fun am
I going to have in 30 minutes so I'd
rather watch you for sure definitely
that's a compliment look I'm we could be
friends friends I think you you're
you're I think we're very alike you know
what we're probably more alike than I
would care to admit and I suspect we
will be friends after this um things
move forward then to Wimbledon last year
obviously you're on a tear you're
playing fantastically you are a genius
tennis play I'm going to put that on the
table now I love watching you play
however that you you can let yourself
down Nick let's just put it politely uh
and on one occasion during the
tournament you let yourself down and you
were throwing stuff around and abusing
everyone and I labeled you on this show
the douche of the day let's take a look
at the clip one of my least favorite
people Nick curios you know what bro
you're my douche of the day every day if
you're watching Mr curios I think you do
watch the show just grow up you big
baby any
thoughts yeah but okay look I'm not
going to sit here and say that I'm on my
best behavior all the time but these
clips that you show are only like 10 to
15 seconds worth of what the tennis
match is there's four or 3 to four hours
where I'm incredibly well behaved I'm
mean like competing and I'm playing
World Class tennis then you choose to
show 10 seconds of a 4-Hour match I mean
I can't control that but I do understand
like sometimes yeah I I could be a
douche on the tennis court but that's
just what it is I mean let's be clear it
I do hours and hours a week of of live
television uh I think to a pretty high
standard but if I was to spend 10
seconds every week throwing throwing
things at the cameraman and uh swearing
and shouting and throw my toys at the
Prem people would focus on that Nick
probably not the rest of my
programming okay but again you you again
you are exaggerating it's not every week
it's not every week there goes there's
like months and months where nothing
happens and then the minute something
happens again you just say that oh he
here he is doing it again where it could
be like a 6 month Hiatus of me not doing
anything so I mean look there's only so
much control I can have well the main
reason you and you're also acting as if
I'm the only tennis player who does
these things no no you're not some of
the legends of the sport have broken
rackets oh yes no well no no you're the
modern day John mro I'm going to come to
that because I know that you've got
you've developed a bit of a rapport with
macenroe let's go back to Wimbledon
again uh in the same tournament I then
had a strange feeling a strange feeling
came over me because there was this
furor about you wearing your
Jordans um and you kept insisting on
doing it and you had an altercation with
a journalist and I suddenly found myself
tweeting the following I said he's such
an unrelenting uncompromising douchebag
that to my horror I'm actually beginning
to warm to Nick curios what why to your
horror why why why are you afraid of
liking me I'm just myself I'm not going
to conform to like
look Wimbledon for me is the Pinnacle of
tennis if not one of the biggest sports
sporting um you know events we have in
the world so I have utmost respect for
everything that it represents and every
time I'm there I you know I have
Goosebumps I I understand the this the
relevance of the event and you know I
think I just put my touch on it I'm not
trying to change Wimbleton but Nick cuos
is trying to bring his touch towards
wimon with you know a slight red hat or
some red Jordans majority of is white
like I'm wearing white I'm going out
there playing in front of millions of
fans you know
giving the you know England uh some some
good tennis so I don't understand why I
got so much hate for that and I think
that's a picture that I'll remember for
the rest of my life you know that's when
Nick Kiros is all said and done in his
tennis career making the wion final
putting on that red hat meeting the
queen and you know doing that is is is
pretty cool I think so I can understand
why you're warming up to me well I was
definitely warming up to you and then we
met a incredible Common Ground we
discovered we feel exactly the same way
about somebody else in the World of
Sport and it was Megan rapino the uh
female soccer player as they call it in
America and it came after this clip
where she uh basically treated a young
boy trying to get an autograph I thought
was appalling dismissiveness have we got
the
clip well I gave my my pretty strong
views about this on Twitter uh and you
actually
replied ha ha ha haa one thing me and
peers agree on so we finally bonded over
Megan rapino being a spoiled petulent
brat yeah look again I'm not going to
come on here and and you know criticize
athletes I know that she's got you know
millions of fans worldwide and in this
moment in time she may have been dealing
with things and you may be very
dismissive I'm not going to sit here and
say I've been amazing to every fan that
I've ever signed um you know a tennis
ball for or anything for but you know
every time you know it's it's a young
kind of kid I do my best to try and look
involved because I used to be that
person when I was um young you know I
had my idols and when they signed tennis
balls for me I was always super super
excited so I know the relevance and and
the importance of being present in those
moments and you know someone like me
that I don't know if you know because
you dislike me so much I actually try
and give back a lot to the community and
spend um time with kids and and you know
I actually met a make a wish kid you
know a couple weeks ago and I enjoyed
that type of stuff so um yeah I mean I
don't really like the dismissiveness but
you know I haven't been perfect either
well let me be let me just put this on
the table uh I've actually grown to
really like you and that may be the
worst thing you hear from me all day but
I I actually have because I watched the
the Netflix uh thing uh found out a lot
more about you about your life about
your upbringing what you'd come through
um and the honesty I felt that you
brought to what you'd gone through and
the
self-awareness that you had I felt look
I I wouldn't use a phrase as patronizing
as it felt like you'd grown up but it
definitely felt like you'd evolved as a
human being and we're able to look back
on that period when we first locked
horns and recognize that that was not a
path to any Glory that was just going to
be completely self-defeating would that
be would that be fair yeah I think we
all we all grow off our own um at our
own pace but yeah I definitely look to
look where I was in 2016 where you and I
had to run in and look a bit of credit
would have been nice from you I mean it
was fourth round of wimon against one of
the greatest of all time I thought that
in itself was a pretty good achievement
but um yeah look I've grown up um
immensely um I look back at you know
those Twitter beefs that I've had I've
had one with you I've had one with Drake
and I just look back and I'm just saying
like these is just so so silly and when
I've met all these people that I've had
beef with we actually get a along
extremely well I mean I could imagine
that you and I could go for a beer and
for a drink and we'd have a great time
with all the stories and experiences
that we've both had but yeah that I
guess that Netflix um series was really
good for me personally because it gave a
bit of background into you know people
think that I've been entitled and got
given everything off a plate but you
know when I was young my family didn't
have much you know I had to kind of work
for everything that was thrown my way
and yeah I went through my own struggles
and it was common struggles that most
people do go through so that's why I'm
very relatable so I think that's why it
was very important it's an interesting
part of the Netflix thing where you
there shows about some of the critics
you've had and I I pop up let's take a
look at that you were having a bit of a
interaction if you like the line judges
and at one point I think you said you're
in your '90s you can't see the ball I
hit a ball in right the old man called
it out it was in so so arguably if the
guy was 40 he may not have called that
out do you have any sympathy with how
sometimes they're treated by by players
for example well they're not getting
abused on social media like I have to
deal with my girlfriend deals with hate
messages my family deals with hate
messages I deal with hate
messages okay thank you very much thanks
thank you very
much the man's out of control can you
put up any defense for this antipa and
monster there's plenty of Australians
who think he's an absolute
toour I got to say it's it's slightly
awkward looking at some of the stuff I
said about you with you sitting there
watching me as I do it but um but in a
way you kind of brought that treatment
on yourself you know I would argue I
think you felt like it was part of your
brand you're an un uncompromising Brash
character right and you probably
factored in well this is going to make
me more interesting right not not not on
that particular day first of all Aon
Mullen that person the Australian uh
reporter I have no idea who that person
is so her opinion to me doesn't matter
and I'm I'm I'm happy she had her 5
minutes of fame but um also yeah that
day like I've just played a 4 and 1 half
hour match and I brought my food into
the press conference because I'm not
sure I'm not sure if you've been in
Elite athlete before but when you finish
a match at four for 4 hours you need to
fuel your body because it's a like a
very crucial part of your recovery so I
thought I'd bring my sushi in to the
press conference room because I had
media to do and I didn't want to make
people wait because people have bookings
for the media room so there's a lot of
things that happen behind the scenes
that I got criticized for and you know
many other tennis players have brought
beers into the press conference room
eating in the press conference room and
they don't get absolutely battered in
the media for it I just brought some
sushi and thought I'd kill two birds
with one stone get my media done look
after my nutrition be professional but
obviously that got taken out for a spin
and it was like oh he's eating in a
press conference room he's he's Judas um
but you know that was that was hard but
I mean why would we I I just understand
it's Wimbledon it's one of the biggest
sporting events in the world with
millions of dollars on the line why
would we let line line calls be given to
chance why would we not have electric
line calling or at least give the
players the best chance to compete in a
fair environment so I'm just very black
and white I I'm not trying to act I just
strongly believe that there should be
electronic line calling because then it
doesn't leave hundreds and thousands of
dollars on the line to maybe a chance a
bad day or or someone or something like
that and sorry that I was just looking
after my nutrition with with five bits
of sushi my goodness
jeez you know what I had to eat I'll
give you the I'll give you the first
point I agree with you about the line
calling it is ridiculous if you have
some old crusty at Wimbledon who can
barely see straight ruling something out
when it's here or the other way around
thank you I'm not going to give you
sushi cuz Roger federa would never do
that cuz he's too classy and he'd have
too much respect for the journalist so
that you're you're not going to get pass
on that but I'm not Roger federa you
can't expect everyone to be Roger federa
you can't you can't do that that's
unfair that's very unfair that means 99%
of the tennis tour are not up to Roger
feder standard that that's sport that's
personality like you you know what I
mean he also has nine people in his team
to make sure that he has food ready I
only had three I had my girlfriend I had
my best friend my agent and my physio so
we don't I don't have the luxury of
having 13 people to tie my shoelaces
like Roger federa or you know make sure
I have a white vest to walk on the court
with I have to do these things mostly on
my own so that's where a bit of
understanding like to compare Nikos to
Roger Federer is ridiculous well hang on
I'm not comparing you to him as a player
or anything to do with his Entourage or
anything I'm just saying he'd never eat
sushi at a press conference which is
something you don't need to be told what
to do do you but but what what's what's
wrong with that I'm I'm looking after my
nutrition and it's it's a very common
thing that tennis players do in in every
tournament it's not it's not abnormal
for a player to eat or snack on
something because I just came off the
court I didn't have any time to do
recovery they they told me that was my
press conference time so I had to eat I
had to eat what how would you feel what
do you want me to do how would you feel
if while we're talking right now in an
interview that's going to be beamed
around the world I just start munching
on
sushi
but you but you didn't play you didn't
play at Wimbledon for 4 hours you have
no idea what i' had ample time to
prepare to get breakfast tennis yeah but
ten tennis tennis is one of the only
sports in the world where you don't know
how long the match will go for and it's
it could be an hour and a half it could
be 4 hours so plans change you have to
be very adapt you have to be able to
adapt that's why Novak's for me the
greatest athlete because there's not
like it's like a football match where
you play a certain 90 minutes or you
know it's a NBA game where you have 48
minutes of it's like there's so many
things and intangibles that can happen
like I had to eat it was not obviously
if I my match win for an hour and a half
I would have said oh yeah no I'll eat
later but I had to eat at that time okay
look I'm not going to sit here and and
like if I was talking to Raphael n doll
or Novak jovic i''d be like yeah no 100%
but P's Morgan it's like it's a
problem well I tell you what is a
problem for me is your inference earlier
that I don't understand the mentality of
an elite tennis player I'd like to play
you a clip of when I took on Serena
Williams in New
[Applause]
York that was nice oh you're carrying on
like Nick curios it's like you know what
I'm proud of you it was I'm proud of you
it wasn't Wimbledon but you know I
didn't want to play that clip but you
forced me into it with your taunting
about me not being Elite level tennis
player that is me beating the greatest
female player in history uh I'm not
claiming any credit obviously I'm a man
I'm more powerful and faster um more
skillful uh but a win a win yeah you
looked good your Technique was a lot
better than I thought but you looked in
a bit better shape back then Pier so how
about when I get healthy we uh we take
it to the courts and and we sort it out
once and for all well you know what I'll
do that and uh and actually I do need a
bit more sushi in my diet that's
true got to lay off the PS I want to
play your more serious clip nick uh
because it's good fun joshing with you
and you obviously got a good sense of
humor but I want to play another clip
from the the Netflix uh Series this is
where you talk about when you went off
the
rails I hated the kind of person I
was I was
drinking abusing drugs
lost my relationship my family pushed
all my close friends
away you could tell I was hurting like
my whole arm was covered in scars and
that's why I actually got my arm sleeve
to cover it
all 2019 was
tough Nick was me yeah Nick
was I've just never seen someone go
through and that's why sometimes my God
I get so upset when someone
says like bad things about him because
they don't
know I was genuinely contemplating if I
wanted to commit
suicide I found that really shocking
Nick and I read another interview you
gave a print interview and you talked
about feeling incredibly lonely uh very
disconnected from your family you were
drinking heavily sometimes 20 30 drinks
a night before big matches taking drugs
party till dawn on one occasion at
Wimbledon in 2018 your manager couldn't
get hold of you and used a phone app to
track you and found you were 26 miles
away passed out in a random stranger's
house and you would spend days lying in
the dark uh cutting and burning yourself
um and I I got to say I found that
incredibly shocking but also incredibly
courageous of you to put all this out
there for the public to to learn
yeah um I think I was at the point of my
career last year when I came out about
it and I was ready to open up I think I
think last year I was actually ready to
just put my story out there and you know
when I watch those clips that you just
played they're really emotional but at
the same time inside I feel a lot better
than I I used to feel about that and you
know I feel like the I've helped so many
people like after I opened up about it
and put on social media and obviously
the Netflix documentary highlighted a
lot more of it um I've almost been a
beacon for people who are struggling and
you know when they feel like they're
overwhelmed and they're going towards
you know drinking and drugs and stuff
they they open up and they feel like
unrelatable because if someone like me
can first of all make it to the tennis
tour and then deal with all that as well
as playing like those those nights that
I was having were before playing people
like Rafa on the D um you know playing
quality players on the HP tour and and
still being successful I guess where I
was in the darkest period of my life so
if I'm ble to pull myself out of it um
that's one of being the most powerful
thing in my career is people come to me
with genuine issues and they send me
photos in my Instagram DMS of them you
know self Haring and and genuinely
wanting to commit suicide and I have
conversations with these people
sometimes you know I've had phone calls
with these people and you know that's
making a real difference for my career
and I'm just really proud that I'm you
know I watch those clips and I'm not
really emotional about it I start
smiling because I know now the
importance of family and how much those
loved ones actually just wanted to care
for me and protect me through all the
criticism and you know when I couldn't
deal with it but now you know it's it's
night and day different so what was the
absolute Rock Bottom moment for you when
you look back at that period oh there
was it was I don't think there was one
select um moment I think it was just all
a year and a half to two years of just
complete just harm I think it was it it
was it was pretty dark to be honest um
you know I W I won tournaments you know
on the professional tour drinking every
night self Haring I used to you know was
burning things on my arm cutting myself
for fun and you know I had people around
me saying this is not normal behavior
and I did have people around me that
were caring but I just it was almost the
more I kept doing it it became an
addiction of like pain and and you know
I just didn't like I I hated myself I
hated waking up and being Nick curios I
hated going to places and tournaments
and no one actually wanted to talk to me
at face value they just wanted me to be
the the Entertainer or the crazy neurio
so I didn't feel like who I actually was
was of any worth and it just got out of
control but then you know I somehow dug
myself out of the hole so nothing you
say on Twitter can can phase me peer
nothing that is very obvious actually um
what also came clear was that Andy
Murray uh saw these marks on your arms
and he reached out to you didn't he uh
how important was that yeah Andy and was
always a big supporter of of me as soon
as I came on the tour he I don't know he
kind of
saw a working progress I I think and and
he always try and took me under his wing
and then he realized later in my career
that I was I don't think I was coachable
or could you know I was on my own path
but he was always someone that was
looking out for me and one of the best
for me so yeah he saw it and he said
what's that on your arm and it was
pretty bad at that stage and when you
know these These are people in the
locker room so I'd be in the locker room
and they people would be able to see
myself harm so I could only imagine what
people would think when they were
actually versing me on the tennis court
they're like wow this guy is mentally in
a in in a storm at the moment and he's
still trying to play and um it would
have been alarming for for some of these
players to see and Andy was saying look
you should obviously was trying to give
me advice on it but I was just so stuck
in my ways at that time that I didn't
listen and obviously I'm very thankful
if he ever watches this I'm sure curios
and Piers Morgan I'm sure he's going to
tune in at some stage um so yeah I thank
I thank him a lot you know I've got to
know Andy over the years is there's a
lot more to him than than the kind of
dead pan uh expressionless guy that
people think he is he's actually he's a
really funny guy he's very smart uh he's
very aware I think about his reputation
finds it funny and so on but for you it
sounds like he was also when it really
mattered he was trying to be a really
good friend of yours yeah we still we
still you know stay in touch from time
to time and I'm just really happy that
he's able to come back and compete you
know when he came back after his injury
and you know people were expecting him
to to be at the top of the sport again
with with these Gods like Novak Nadal
and federa it was more just the fact of
him still being there and to come back
after an injury like that I was super
happy for him and yeah he's always been
you know when we see each other in the
locker room we know that there's a lot
of banter going to be happening and I
think we get along extremely well our
humor is very similar um I think it's
hilarious so when he got you know when
people were branding him boring and no
personality I was like they just don't
know the trandy M yeah I completely
agree he's couldn't be more different
was there one person who said something
to you which managed to start the
beginning of the future for you when you
look back was there somebody a
conversation or a moment which went
where you went okay cuz you're you're
talking a lot about not listening to
people there must have been a moment I
guess when either you listen to someone
or perhaps yourself yeah you just
touched on it um that everyone that was
you know in my circle my loved ones
always told me the right thing to do but
I I guess it was just conversations that
I had with myself um it was you know at
the end of the day you can have everyone
around you telling you which direction
to go but if you don't think that's the
right way then you're not going to get
out of it and I I just had a
conversation with myself and I was like
look we got to got to do something about
it so I I I just tried little bit by
little just to get some good habits make
some right choices um and yeah look last
year
was the best year of arguably the best
year of my career nearly won a grand
slam um had the third best season on the
planet um and I just from where I was to
that it was so emotional for me
personally cuz I just didn't think it
was possible I thought my time had gone
where I'd have success off the court and
on the court you know I had a great
partner I had a great friendship group
and had amazing success and I I'd never
thought it was possible to be this happy
but I think that it's just more I think
it was me just day by day making the
right choices I actually wanted you to
win that final thanks uh I mean I'm
surprised you've ever wanted me to win a
tennis match I think you'd rather me
just lose all the time well
distinctively I don't like Australians
winning anything particularly Cricket uh
but no I did I felt like you you just
electrified the tournament and you know
I I I thought that this is a guy who's
complicated but I used to like watching
Mack androe you know when I was young I
remember ma Andro getting a lot of bad
media bad attention but I I I realized
over time much more of course since he's
given interviews rather like you're
doing these days
that a lot of it was driven by just This
ferocious stuff going on inside him this
turmoil this desire to be the best but
also a flawed complicated character you
know which if you are one of those if
you're a very straightforward well
adjusted person then I guess you can
rise from the top of a sport a lot
easier than if you're
complex yeah I agree and I think that's
been uh uh very hard for people watching
the viewers my fans even sometimes my my
closest friends or my family they always
want me to be I guess better somewhere
like maybe not lose your temper or play
this way or do this and do that but
that's just not who I am and I feel like
over time people have kind of being more
comfortable with me just being Nicos
it's like okay we we know that we're if
we buy tickets and Nicos we don't know
what we're going to get we could get
explosive tennis we could get
entertaining tennis we could get
something absolutely off planet Earth
that you've never seen before he might
do something crazy and I think that's
part of the the show I think Sport and
entertainment is one and I think that's
why it's important you have to have
different personalities in sport
otherwise it's just it will get a bit
stale and boring and I think you look at
that c pass match with me and wimon it
was it was insane like it was incredible
it was one of the best matches I've ever
been a part of because of the crowd was
involved the people were involved they
made a Netflix do documentary of it um
so I mean look I've had I've definitely
had a lot of fun um playing my style of
tennis but look if you're going to
compare me to the greats of tennis then
you've you've set me up for failure when
you were mackenro get together I does he
give you advice having gone through
pretty pretty similar stuff when he was
a young
player um look I've never been I don't
think I've ever been defaulted from a
match you know he he broke all his
rackets and had no rackets to play with
and had to get defaulted so I don't
think I've ever done that I've walked
off the court but um yeah when me and
Johnny Mack first met each other I feel
like we were both a bit on edge at La
cup because he was team world's captain
and I was like team world's kind of
camaraderie captain in that sense and we
both didn't know how we were going to be
and then we sat down we had you know
dinner together and we realized that um
we're pretty similar in the in the sense
where we're just we're just we're trying
to be ourselves and we're just trying to
be original and authentic and I feel
like he was really surprised that I was
intellectually pretty switched on and
and he doesn't really try and give me
advice anymore he he knew pretty pretty
pretty early that I was my own person
you said I don't mind being the villain
I've definitely experienced stadiums
where not one person's been going for me
it's a great feeling you find some
really dark energy when the whole
stadium doesn't want you to win those
are some of the best moments the only
thing I've had like that in my life was
when I was a judge on America's Got
Talent and I was playing the bag you
know the tough meanie judge and I know
that feeling to a degree in the sense of
when they're all booing me I used to
love it and so I I do get that dark
energy part I've had it in a very
different way but I get it and I used to
get off on it right I mean and you
clearly do I've seen you um just talk
about that for a moment what's that
feeling like when they're all going nuts
and they're all shouting at you and all
barracking you and booing what do you
actually feel yeah you feel you feel
like you feel like the the bad guy in in
a movie you feel like the main villain
and I love it you know I used to love
going out not So Much Anymore when when
I go out to stadiums around the world
now it's like people are cheering people
are going crazy people wanting to see
the curios I guess the show and and
they're very supportive where back in
the day when I used to show up to places
it was like even for practice even when
I entered the site I needed extra
security guards compared to the other
players because of the hate people just
used to hate seeing my presence around
the courts and they would boo my
practices they would throw in Shanghai
one year people with throwing glass
bottles on the court it was just it was
it was a riot and something just drove
me to it was just like addictive every
time I went out on the court I knew that
I could spoil someone's day I knew that
I could just upset someone be be the bad
guy in The Fairy Tale so it was it was a
good feeling but um I think being loved
is a little bit better being being
appreciated and and being supported is
definitely I think healthier but yeah
the the villain was good for a little
bit the um I mean you talked about Mack
androe being defaulted and you were very
proud of the fact you've never got that
far you are the most fined player in the
history of tennis uh 452,000
of fines are you proud of that record it
goes to charity so on the flip side I
could be the most generous ATP player
ever you said that with a completely
straight look I'm not I'm not sometimes
when I
watch look sometimes when I watch my
highlights back and I realized look I
probably shouldn't have done that look
there's some some regret in some of my
actions obviously like I'm not going to
sit here and say no that was always
warranted no sometimes I do cross the
line but competitors out there know that
and I think if you look at other sports
you know trash talking's normal you know
these behaviors aren't as I guess
repulsive but because it's tennis it's
it's under a microscope it's very
traditional and I understand that but um
look you're talking to someone who
idolizes NBA and loves that culture and
loves to trash talk and I think it's all
healthy competition but yeah some of
these behaviors aren't you know great
and I've realized that the older I've
become millions of kids around the world
you know are watching my game and they
want to meet me and I know that I try
and have to you I have to try and set a
better example
but look I can't change the past so I
just got to try be better now I guess
you um I I know you don't well you s you
don't want it you can't comment about
the clip I'm about to show you from
Wimbledon last year but it was a famous
clip and really I just want to play it
to see what your facial reactions like
let's take a
look okay but why is she still here
she's drunk out of a l in the first row
speaking to me in the middle of the game
what's acceptable nothing is acceptable
okay so kick her out I don't know which
one is it I know exactly which one it is
tell me it's the one in the the the
dress with the the one that looks like
she's had about 700 drinks
bro I got to say I did laugh yeah that's
just it was h of the moment and that's
not the only time that something like
that's happened you know you you're
playing in the biggest tournaments in
the world Wimbledon Australian Open
French Open US Open and at these crucial
moments I think people sometimes
Spectators they don't understand that it
can just be a fall in concentration for
20 seconds and then that can swing the
entire tennis match and especially
against someone like Novak I needed you
know the Stars to a line that day but
yeah look Heat of the Moment quick chat
you and I both know In the Heat of the
Moment We Do up with some of our best
stuff so um yeah look it's true I can't
control sometimes I would like the crowd
to understand the the severity of just
one point in a tennis match one point in
a tennis match can swing for the next 20
minutes so yeah it's it's it's it's
tough at at the uh at the start of your
career when you were about 20 and things
were really going off the rails Shane
War the late great Australian cricketer
who was a good friend of mine he he
wrote an open letter to you it says
after that defeat to Andy Murray after I
did my my tweet to you actually and he
said dear Nick curios I was to read read
what he wrote dear Nick curios we all
realize you're only 20 have a lot to
learn buddy please don't waste your
talent everyone in the world especially
us Australians want to respect you
remember respect is way more important
than being liked you need to respect the
game of tennis and yourself we all make
mistakes but it's how we learn from them
and the way we conduct ourselves when we
lose that shows true character you're
testing our patients mate show us What
You're Made Of and how hungry you are to
be the best the world it's time to step
up and start winning no excuses no shame
in losing but show us you'll never give
up you'll give everything to be the best
you can be respect is earned not given I
believe in you I know you can do it but
now's the time my friend my first
question is did you did you see that
open letter at the time uh yeah I saw it
um and didn't read it um but yeah uh
look I feel like I've been the closest
Australian player in the last decade to
win a grand slam I was I made the final
um I've had a pretty successful career I
feel like I've won a lot more than I've
lost um able to provide for my family
friends um and yeah respected by
millions around the world obviously um
and yeah I'm just I've done it my way so
look at the at at at the end of the day
I know that these other Australian
athletes um you know just wanted to see
me SU and I've only ever supported most
of them as well and I've only wanted the
best for them I've never never going to
be the first one to go out on social
media and put someone down if someone
does that to me I'll respond but um yeah
look I mean I look back at that letter
and I look back of how far I've come and
I'd say he would be proud for sure I
think he absolutely would and there's a
lot about your personality which is very
warning like you know it wasn't like he
was any uh by his own admission he was
no angel um this was a guy that went
through a lot of stuff himself I think
he genuinely was trying to give you
advice from someone who'd been there in
the cold face of The Cauldron of
international sport recognized you were
young saw some traits perhaps of his own
and was genuinely trying to help you did
you ever meet Shane after that no never
I never was able to meet Shane I guess
his schedule would have been excuse me
um his schedule would have been crazy
and obviously with my travel I think
that would have been one person that
would have probably we would have got
along really really well yeah um yeah
look um I I I haven't met too many of
these Australian athletes just cuz the
schedules are so different and we just
have a lot going on your early story uh
Nick is really fascinating because you
were the last of three children uh Born
To Georgia father and nil your mother um
your dad immigrated to Australia from
Greece age seven and was a a decorator
your mom was born in Malaysia as part of
the Royal Family actually and moved to
Australia with her mother when she she
was 12 and became a software engineer
it's an unusual pathway uh for for
someone like you to have come from this
this background and this journey your
parents went on how much is their I I
guess resilience they would have had to
have had to have gone through all this
when they were young how much of that
streak is in you from that do you think
huge I mean that's where most of my
motivation comes from you know my dad is
nearly getting on the latest ages of 60
and continues to work every day you know
his mindset um you know came with
nothing and everything that he's built I
guess he he sees me kind of carrying the
work and doing you know these interviews
or you know being an entrepreneur in a
couple things and obviously playing the
tennis I think he's super proud because
he sees you know some of his work ethic
in in me and I try and that's really
part of my motivation and you know my
mom obviously has dealt with so many
different health issues over the last
decade and especially over the last two
years you know so every day with her is
a blessing and I understand that and and
it's it's it's been hard playing
majority of my career with my mom having
severe health problems it's been tough
but she's one of the strongest women I
know and um yeah those I I have honestly
everyone that comes to my house they
understand how amazing my parents are
they they they look after everyone they
feed everyone they make sure they try
and connect with everyone make everyone
feel special and yeah I mean look they
they're the best I I have no complaints
they with a I look back at some of the
the dinners that we had you know we had
$20 for three for three children at
dinners and and and I didn't know any
different I I I was growing up thinking
I had the best life so um she my mom was
awesome my dad's awesome so that's yeah
yeah in in May this year your mother was
held up at gunpoint by a masked man at
the family's home in in CRA you gave
Chase and actually injured your foot
resulting in missing the the French Open
that's a scary thing to happen
particularly with your mother having
already going through Health ISS issues
yeah just just tough you know thinking
about that moment it's still very raw it
was actually quite recent
um just yeah that's that's something
that I never thought would that my
career would bring would be people you
know coming to my doorstep where my my
family have lived for 30 plus years and
you know you hold a gun to my to my mom
and and ask for a car it's like to to to
come steal a car
it's it's you could take the car but the
that you've left on on my mom and our
family is is I think you can't heal ever
from something like that um so yeah look
it my career has brought me many
beautiful things and the platform I have
to help people's amazing but these are
things that just I have to deal with
that majority of humans don't deal with
and it's been really hard for the family
to get over that um yeah it was just a
it was
a horrific morning to be honest I just
remember my mom screaming and I I I
rushed to the front door cut my foot on
on something and it was just gashing out
blood and it was just it was a disaster
so yeah I mean look we're but we're a
strong contingent we're going to get
through it and my mom's doing you know
she's seeing people to help her um
mental state o over it still and you
know she'll be she'll be fine did you
what happened to the person that did
this um I think he's you know legally
going to get dealt with and and we'll
see your mother um recently also said
that it she can't watch she play anymore
that it just makes her too anxious and
she stopped watching it how did you feel
about that uh yeah well she's got a
pacemaker now as well so I don't think
she could come to any of my matches um
especially Australian Open or wimon with
the ups and downs and the the craziness
that happens I mean that it's just too
risky so um she watches from home so my
whole team usually comes watch me play
and if I'm in Australia everyone will
come watch live and she'll just stay
back at the accommodation and wherever
we're staying and just watch it on TV
and and support me from there and I know
that she's watching me all the time um
I've stressed that woman out so much and
I'm sorry um I'll say that on probably
one of the biggest shows ever but she
she's really proud of my work and how
much that I've grown but yeah I I just
wish that maybe she can watch me you
know one last time if I you know once I
come back from injury and I'm playing it
this straight open I would love for her
to come for just one more match um that
would be a dream you know to to watch
her cuz she was the one from from day
dot that was always there from under
under eights to 10 to to now so it would
be really really really special if she
can she can tough it out for for a
couple years more she uh did a a a piece
she talked about her own upbringing when
she first came from Malaysia to
Australia age 12 said it was quite
traumatic she said I can remember
sitting on a bench wishing that someone
would ask me to play those memories are
very painful to be isolated to be called
whatever names people call someone with
dark
skin um so that was racism she was
experiencing yeah we've the curios
family has definitely dealt with their
fair share of racism um in Australia
but look it's it's just such a silly
topic for me I I don't like speaking
about it but yeah it's it's been tough
um for us you know some of the legends
of our sport have have told told my me
and my family to go back to where we
came from and you know we've we've I was
born in Australia grown up there and
represented the country for for 27 years
with anything I've done so it's
definitely been something um that we've
had to deal with but it just makes you
stronger I've got incredibly thick skin
and it's all it's all a process and and
one day I hope that this Topic's just
not not mentioned anymore yeah when you
when you said that it's a silly thing
for you do you mean that it's just
something you have to constantly get
asked about deal with and you'd rather
that you could just be judged on the
content literally of your character and
your play than anything to do with your
skin color or background yeah definitely
I just feel like you know you look at my
friendship group I have you know I have
all different types of friends from
everywhere and we just get along so well
and I think it's just such a silly topic
you know we're all human beings at the
end of the day we can all when we work
together we all do some incredible
things together um and yeah you know
whether you're white or black doesn't
matter to me so I'm uh yeah it's just a
very silly topic you um your old Agent
verse spotted you wrote down in his
notepad at the time chubby mouthy but
unbelievable hand skills uh you're
definitely not chubby anymore um and
you've got unbelievable hand skills
still and you're still pretty mouthy so
he was two out of three survived but uh
it's quite amazing your your physical
transformation when you look at that
picture of yourself can you believe that
guy has become one of the great athletes
of his country I mean I'll take that as
you call me good-looking thanks Pier um
my Compliments are hard to come by from
you but yeah look I look at these photos
of when I was young and yeah the the
there's a fair glow up that's for sure
but um yeah look I didn't think I that's
just hope you look at those pictures
when I was young and any kid that has
dreams and and things they want to
achieve just that's that's your
inspiration right there for sure like I
was overweight most of my most of my
life um so if I'm able to pull it
together and and you know just keep
chipping away it doesn't happen
overnight chipping away chipping away
you can get Piers Morgan to call you
good-looking on on on TV
I think I actually said you you'd lost
weight I didn't go as far I say you're
good-looking no don't no we'll Replay
that we'll save that clip I'm definitely
posting that tell me about your love
life because you're very happy uh with
Co haty you met online in 2021 and
within months you took a bold move Nick
curios you tattooed her name on your
thigh that is a perilous thing to do
early in a relationship yeah it is um
yeah me and Co met uh almost we've
almost been together for 2 years
December 31st is our anniversary um so
yeah life with her has been amazing um I
feel like you know you you love someone
when you you know been given a bit of
adversity we you know we did the we
traveled the world together with
airports we had delays you know things
that I've come from the baggage that
I've brought into the relationship she's
she's dealt with it amazing um and we
just get along well everything's easy
with her um and back to the tattoo I was
actually in a tattoo parlor and I was
getting something covered up and then
she was like I was like do you want me
to get you tattooed it was just like I
just threw it out there and then she was
like no no you don't have to and then
secretly I knew that that was me
shooting myself in the foot I was like
oh no I have I have to do it I have to
do it now so she was like no you better
do it and then I had to get a little one
on my on my leg and yeah it's fine you
know she's definitely the one i' I'm P
all that drama in relationships it's
it's it's a special one uh when you said
you were covering something up that
wasn't the name of a previous girlfriend
was it
maybe maybe so you've done your
research actually I was guessing but it
it made sense oh yeah guessing I was I
was legitimately guessing there's
nothing on here that says you were take
getting rid of a previous girl's name
but it makes sense if you're impetuous
and put women's names on your thighs
you're going to have to get rid of some
of them right yeah I guess
so do you think you're going to get
married I know you want four kids she
wants two I know that much but you're
going to get married
how do how do you know how do you know
this stuff you secretly love Nick curios
you're a stalker you know why I know CU
I'm a proper professional journalist at
the top of my game like you in tennis
hey that's true I I'll give you I'll
give you props I'll give you props you
are very professional and yeah look one
day definitely um you know I'm 28 now
and obviously want to have a big family
one day you know I think I'm a very
family orientated person so is she she's
got an amazing family back home in in
Sydney so yeah I I would love to have a
basketball team but like I would try
like to have five six maybe um but yeah
I think she's just set on two so we'll
see I'll ask you a question I asked
Cristiano Ronaldo and Zlatan Ibrahimovic
because you're obviously at that level
um which is let me give you a choice you
can win Wimbledon next year you can beat
jovic in an absolute
Thriller uh or you can have great sex
but you can't have both which which one
you going to
take this is a tough question it's not
really a tough question um I'm taking
option two really cuz look I made the
final already so I mean I'm not going to
lose option two what are you going to do
about your career a lot of rumors flying
around that you were going to give up
retire if you'd beaten jovic last year
but you're still young I mean jovic is
like eight years older than you are you
really going to throw the towel in
anytime soon I mean is are we not in an
era where Cristiano Ronaldo and these
guys they show you can go until 40 I
mean could you not be doing this in five
six years maybe long longer yeah I think
um you know soccer's got a little bit of
a different you know setting you know
you don't have to compete at the
absolute highest level in the eepl or
you know the Lio you you have all these
different leagues where you can get paid
amazing amounts and kind of not play it
maybe you know 60 70% if if that was an
option for tennis definitely I would
reassess my options you know at the
moment I'm dealing with some health
issues so just trying to get back
healthy I I definitely don't see myself
you know going anywhere in any in the
near future but you know I want to get
back on the tour and have one to two
more really really good years and I
think that's possible um and then after
if if there's some more leagues you know
that are offering some nice money then
yeah I I'll definitely look on extending
my career but you know there there's a
lot of work in the tennis world that
needs to be done um and yeah look I'm a
day byday guy I don't like setting goals
or plans I just take every day and see
how my body's feeling and you know when
I have kids one day I want to be able to
you know run outside without pain and
then play with them and and still be
pretty youthful so um yeah look plans
can change you know what you do when you
have kids as I discover with mine is
that the moment they start Behaving
Badly at sport you'll be all over them
stop that behave yourself oh definitely
definitely I'm going to be one of the
strictest parents
[Laughter]
ever you've got a a new show coming out
it's called good trouble which is a
perfect title really is that really how
you see yourself
are you basically the bad boy of tennis
but underneath it you've got a good Soul
yeah I mean that's that's that's a nice
way to put it I think I've been I've
kind of been branded you know the bad
boy of tennis I think everyone who knows
me and that's around me don't I don't
fit that mold at all you know I'm just
authentic but yeah good trouble is the
um is the show that's coming and you
know I'm really super excited about it
we've done Francis tiao um you know Mike
Tyson Gordon Ramsay's coming on it so
it's going to be incredible it's you
know we sit down for for 20 to 25
minutes and we get really intimate about
their Journey you know turning points
who are some of their Idols growing up
their beliefs so yeah it's it's I think
it's like a talk show but almost like we
haven't seen before you know we never
haven't really heard from you know
people like Ordon Ramsey what he went
through his journey um growing up and
the critics and just the I guess the
negativity that these kind of people
have dealt with and how they navigated
through that um you know this this got a
special place in in talk shows for sure
you know who you should be interviewing
for your show me I mean hey do you want
to come on yes we could we could set it
up it would be pretty good that would be
I think round two after this interview I
think after this interview airs the
public will be clamoring for another for
a rematch somewhere and it may as well
be on your terms and I I'm going to ask
you some deep questions Pi we're going
to get deep and
emotional I love forward to it Nick
curios it's been actually a great
pleasure and I mean that uh you you
given a great interview uh I've grown to
know you a lot better and I think
understand you a lot better and like I
say I was cheering you on last summer
and I can't wait for you to be back in
action and I feel like we should go to
the dog and fox in wion village where I
used to go as a kid and we should just
have a few pints and you know start take
this Bromance to the next stage oh
you're twisting my arm I don't know if I
can I don't know if I can take you up on
a few beers who
knows Nick curios thank you very much
see you peers see you later